bienvenidos de vuelta vamos a hacer un
problema de energía potencial con un
resorte comprimido pero hagámoslo con un
problema más interesante aunque digamos
que tenemos una especie de vuelta que
está hecho de hielo que es lo que quiere
decir digamos que tenemos aquí
y un pedazo de hielo pero que en
determinado momento empieza a tomar esta
forma
digamos empieza a tomar una forma
circular y da esta vuelta muy bien
quizás este no fue un dibujo muy preciso
vamos a corregirlo un poco de este lado
pero el punto es que esta vuelta está
hecha de hielo y estoy pensando en que
está hecha de hielo para poder suponer
que no hay fricción ok y recordemos que
siempre hay fricción pero para este
problema vamos a suponer que no hay muy
bien y no sólo eso vamos a suponer que
aquí hay digamos un muro y de este muro
se vamos a dar un resorte y como lo
hemos estado pintando siempre vamos a
ponerlo de verde muy bien ahí tenemos
nuestro resorte y en este resorte vamos
a poner una una cajita o un cubito que
también es de hielo
ok ahí está nuestro cubo de hielo y
vamos a suponer que tiene una masa de 4
kilogramos además vamos a suponer que la
constante que la constante de nuestro
resorte es10 ok vamos a suponer que es
10 y por supuesto también vamos a
suponer que estamos en la tierra
porque es donde donde nos interesa
hacer nuestro experimento de física que
estamos pintando aquí y bueno vamos a
suponer también que nuestro resorte
digamos tiene su estado natural en este
punto y que hasta acá estamos
comprimiendo y queremos saber cuál es
esta distancia x pero para qué es esta
distancia x ahí te va la pregunta que
realmente quiero que lo que pensemos en
este vídeo cuánto debemos comprimir este
resorte para que al soltar el bloque
digamos al soltar el resorte este empuje
al bloque y pueda dar una vuelta
completa digamos a esta a esta no sé
cómo decirle a esta vuelta de hielo
digamos ahora para poder descifrar
cuánto tenemos que comprimir necesitamos
decir que esta vuelta es circular aunque
yo sé que mi dibujo no está circular
pero vamos a suponer que sí lo es y que
tiene un radio de un metro quiere decir
que
la altura esta altura
es de 2 metros muy bien entonces la
pregunta es cuánto hay que comprimir
para que es al soltarlo y empuje a este
bloque de hielo de una de la vuelta
completa y la parte importante para
completar esto o para completar la
vuelta es fijarnos en el punto más alto
de esta vuelta verdad es fijarnos en el
punto más alto de la vuelta entonces la
el bloque de hielo debe llevar
suficiente velocidad para no caer y esa
es decir esa velocidad debe superar la
aceleración que va hacia abajo por
efecto digamos de la aceleración
centrípeta ok y a lo mejor tú puedes
decir oye este problema se ve súper
complicado tenemos un resorte un bloque
una vuelta alturas y demás pero en
realidad
como que la idea en física es que si
tienes un problema súper complicado lo
más probable es que lo esté es realmente
abordando de una forma súper complicada
así que lo que vamos a utilizar en este
en este problema va a ser
algo mucho más sencillo y va a ser
utilizando la energía potencial y la
energía cinética además de la ley de la
conservación de la energía porque ya
hemos visto en vídeos anteriores que si
uno tiene
y un objeto en movimiento entonces la
energía potencial más la energía
cinética se conservan en todo momento de
su movimiento verdad así que pensemos
cuál es la energía potencial inicial y
eso lo podemos utilizar o más bien lo
podemos descifrar de lo que vimos en el
vídeo anterior verdad la energía
potencial inicial quiere es en la
energía potencial que vamos a obtener en
este objeto al inicio del experimento es
decir cuando comprimimos por el
resultado que obtuvo más bien la fórmula
que descubrimos en el vídeo anterior
esto es un medio por k por x cuadrada
muy bien aquí por supuesto x cuadrada es
lo que tenemos que obtener esto es igual
a que la k vale 10 verdad y un medio de
10 es 5 y tenemos 5x cuadrada y vamos a
tratar de ver cuál es la longitud de x
que hay que comprimir para que este este
bloque alcance a dar toda la vuelta muy
bien
pensemos en este punto en este punto el
más alto de digamos de esta vuelta
llevamos cierta velocidad que es
tangencial
a la vuelta y que es perpendicular a la
aceleración que va hacia abajo muy bien
entonces lo que sí sabemos es que la
energía total digamos la energía la
energía total pues lo podemos calcular
como la energía potencial final es decir
la que vamos a llevar en este punto más
la energía cinética final verdad eso es
la energía total en ese punto muy bien
entonces vamos a ver quién es la energía
cinética final la energía cinética final
como la calculamos esto es un medio por
la masa por la velocidad al cuadrado eso
ya lo sabemos verdad y lo que sí sabemos
también es que la energía potencial
final es igual a la masa por la
aceleración debido a la gravedad por la
altura
vamos a ver qué tenemos que hacer para
calcular la energía cinética final y
aquí vamos a utilizar el resultado en
donde la aceleración centrípeta es igual
a la velocidad al cuadrado sobre r es
cuando hacemos un movimiento a lo largo
de un círculo verdad entonces en este
caso tenemos un radio de un metro verdad
entonces tenemos que la aceleración
centrípeta es la velocidad al cuadrado
sin embargo la aceleración centrípeta en
este caso pues es la aceleración de la
gravedad así que tenemos 9.8 igual a la
velocidad al cuadrado entonces uno
podría decir bueno la velocidad es la
raíz cuadrada de 9.8 pero lo que
nosotros necesitamos es de cuadrada que
es justamente este número vamos a llamar
a este número g sólo para hacer más
fácil las cuentas y ya después cuando lo
necesitemos sacamos el valor exacto de g
entonces la energía cinética
es un medio por la masa que es un medio
por cuatro que son dos y la velocidad al
cuadrado era de verdad que es 9.8 vamos
a dejarlo hasta este punto aquí muy bien
ahora vamos a fijarnos en la energía
potencial final esto es masa por lage
por h entonces la masa valía 4
y h vale dos verdades la altura la
altura de aquí al suelo son dos metros y
estos son 8 g así que ya tenemos cuánto
vale la energía cinética final y la
energía potencial final la energía
potencial final son 8 g la energía
cinética final son 2 g y por lo tanto la
energía total son 10 g esta energía
total debe coincidir con la energía
inicial verdad que solo tenemos energía
potencial así que estos 10 g deben ser
5x cuadrada y esto está muy bien porque
justo x es lo que queríamos calcular
verdad así que qué es lo que tenemos
podemos dividir entre 5 y tendremos que
x cuadrada es igual a 10 entre 5 que son
2 por g y entonces la equis vale raíz
cuadrada de 2
muy bien entonces ahora sí podemos sacar
la calculadora vamos a ver y ponemos dos
por 9.8 eso nos da 19.6 y si sacamos
raíz cuadrada esto es 4.42 7 vamos a
dejarlo como 4.43 así que esto será 4.43
y estamos en las unidades de metro y
esto es una aproximación verdad porque
quitamos varios varias cifras decimales
entonces si te das cuenta no fue un
problema tan difícil lo único que
teníamos que garantizar es que la
energía inicial fuera igual a la energía
final que la energía final la podríamos
calcular como la suma de la potencial
más la cinética verdad entonces
utilizando la fórmula que encontramos en
el vídeo anterior para la energía
potencial de un resorte teníamos que
igualar la energía cinética del
movimiento de este bloque en este punto
más la energía potencial en este punto y
ojo esta energía potencial que
calculamos de este lado
es la energía potencial debido a la
gravitación verdad a la a la fuerza de
gravedad pero bueno en resumen lo que lo
que teníamos que hacer era producir
suficiente energía al inicio como para
que dé toda la vuelta y eso era todo así
que nos vemos en el próximo vídeo